it's good to see you sir how always
great so Nance calling that - he's
calling Super Bowl 53 as well what do
you think of when you see that again
right there bring back bring back some
back memories and I remember telling the
guys before that play rich I said guys
remember one day we're gonna be old and
great you know and I said when we look
back on this that that clip we don't
remember it we don't remember the
feelings we had and right before that
play I remember Chris Tillman my left
guard he said to me let's go get it
right now and I knew I knew it was over
before it's never I knew we were gonna
get the record because he said that you
knew that they're gonna blow up in the
proper hole for you right
well they they they knew they wanted it
more than I did you know and if you look
at their play my full-back Lorenzo Neil
fell down Loney Loney fell down watch
him look he falls down and so there was
two guys out there I said oh you got a
block one guy I'm sorry
rest of my life I'm gonna be the guy
that no well there's any guy with a
sense of you root can handle it's
alright cuz he's crazy as you know he's
a totally crazy that guy and so you know
I mean seeing the reaction right there
that your linemen gave you know that
looked like a line that was properly
taken care of by their star running back
what did what you get come on let's be
honest here oh man I've done all kinds
of things I got Umbro likes watches I
got him brand new flat-screen TVs and
one year I I bought him a round-trip
ticket anywhere in the world they wanted
to go I paid for you know so guys were
going in coach you know those big guys
you have to do that anywhere they want
to do it you have to do it so what's
your philosophy on rewarding hosts of
shows that
- analysis for the big ol hug like like
we did before it was great and I don't
never forget that one
you know when I'm older and grayer I
won't forget that but I mean and and
whenever you call on me I'm here no no
that you've done that you've done that I
appreciate that and I appreciate you
trying to change the subject but you
know I mean I'm I'm kind of like blowing
open the holes for you to analyze the
sport just to drop your poll what do you
know yet a man who has everything a man
who has everything
tickets to anywhere I want to go in so I
don't if you heard we were talking about
before the idea of making a challenge
for a penalty if possible and if you get
it wrong you get a penalty thrown on you
do you what would you think of something
like that so we're calling in a
judgement channel a judgment challenge
yeah
so when I think of judgement I think of
time okay and so time because when you
go to see a judge what usually happens
they take time yes
you know to rule on your case yes and so
I think of time I think of how long is
this gonna take to rule a judgement
challenge true on it you know and so the
game might be extended you know go well
into three to three-and-a-half hours
four hours I think that's something that
we just have to keep in mind I do like
the idea though I like the idea but if
we could keep it snappy well we got to
keep it going that's true because you
know players you're sitting around just
waiting for the momentum to continue and
fans they get bored you know even when
I'm at home watching the game sometimes
and there's a challenge and it's taking
forever no I got get up and go somewhere
else and didn't come back
like we don't want thatis no we don't
people but what we definitely don't want
is something like happened at the NFC
champion so I would I would call up an
extra minute or a minute and a half if
it takes that long
now I understand you got to keep it
tight but I want to prevent from what
happening
from what happened from happening God we
have to you brought up a good point
though that I guess there is gonna be a
penalty on the coach if your challenges
and misses correct then the coach is not
gonna just throw it around like it's not
a manhole cover you know like because I
don't want people starting to challenge
or was the off sauce was d4 really off
sighs well let's let's challenge it you
know yes he was also you know although I
was holding my breath and they say he
was offsides on my oh here comes the
replay oh my god right you know like
he's got to be offsides certainly after
we just saw and like what would be
challengeable like what penalties is it
just pass interference is it you know
holding what are we talking about I
would say everything see I would say
anything and then but you're still
you're still not expanding the number of
challenges and you still have to you
know create some sort of a stopwatch you
do it three minutes tops
four minutes left in the game there's
five minutes left
well it keeps me from at that point I
haven't challenged all game what keeps
me from slowing the game down at that
point and challenging every little thing
how many well they've challenged every
little thing and you get it wrong and it
suddenly its first in 30 who cares
because I'm taking the chance I'm behind
anyway behind by ten five minutes to go
who cares I'm gonna give it a shot abuse
of the system LaDainian Tomlinson here
on the Rich Eisen show can you still
believe Brady and Belichick are back at
it still I mean that's incredible the
number of the number of teams and with
all due respect first ballot Hall of
Famers that they prevented from getting
to where they have now gone for a ninth
time Wow
you could just run the list here I can't
believe they're still here yeah so I
played 11 years she dead they've been to
the Superbowl nine times help and I
didn't get there once right think about
that right and I was one pick away from
being drafted by the Patriots what
happened
the Chargers draft I know that's what
happened they
they didn't let saw they didn't come up
and come get you so I went to so I went
on the visit to the Patriots and that's
when charlie weis was off his
coordinator and I go to Boston and I
really like to visit I like Charlie I
love Charlie Weis you meet with Bill I
did me with Bill
you know we sat in his office right
above the stadium right there were you
looking out at the stadium and we really
just sat there we really didn't talk
about much we just looked at each other
looked at each other saying it was
awkward I mean I just you know you know
how bill is he just there's only a few
things he probably wants to know about
you and I guess he was trying to get a
sense of you know was i passionate about
football as mulch coach coaches do right
and invest the first-round pick on a guy
you want to make sure they're passionate
and so but after that we just kind of
you know I don't remember much
conversation so do you think because I'm
not gonna be your fifth overall and
they're choosing cities they had the six
pick the six pick this is the year that
Brady was about to be the lowest in to
exaggerate --mess okay
and so this is coming off of the 2000
season in which Brady was drafted and
Bledsoe and the Patriots didn't do as
well as they had thought they could do
you think they would have chosen you if
you were available well they said they
were gonna choose me charlie weis
promised me if I was there at sticks
because they needed a running back they
need a running back bad that year and so
uh you know when the Chargers drafted me
I think they took Richard Seymour
have you ever brought up to Brady when
you've seen him I never brought it up
you can pin Robin his bat always I
always thought about you know what would
that be like do Antoine Smith all doers
yeah I know little different no way yeah
I'm kind of getting freaked out we had
Steve Smith on the show just yesterday
saying that he had a chat with Belichick
when he was leaving Carolina and he was
already
mitad verbally to Baltimore and his
phone went off and he looked down at the
call waiting and it said William
Belichick on the phone and he was
basically like is this hello you know
and it really was him and he came close
to doing that but he'd already made a
commitment to Baltimore and he thought
that that was gonna work out that's one
person a name that she really is hard to
turn down right you know you look at
your phone and says William Belichick
yeah it's like the president so what do
you think is going to happen in Super
Bowl what do you think is gonna happen
you know I've thought about this quite a
bit I think you know so the Patriots
over the years have won obviously I
think because think about the AFC they
see the same people over and over right
yeah you know the same teams so they got
that blueprint on how to beat those
teams they scheme against those teams
every year but when it comes to the NFC
they don't see those teams a lot and so
is this a situation like last year with
Doug Peterson and his team gave the
Patriots fits because the Patriots
haven't seen Doug Peterson system a lot
is this one of those situations where
with Shaun McVeigh's system because they
haven't seen it a lot and they don't
know the blueprint of how to stop Shaun
sis system will they be able to stop
them or will the Rams be able to score
like like to fit like Philly did last
year and if they are if they are able to
score I think the Rams win the game
because I don't see the Patriots scoring
over 30 on the Rams defense not the way
they plan Wade Phillips has has seen
Brady and that offense enough to know
what it takes to scheme up a plan to
stop them right I do see the Patriots
scoring 24 27 but can the rounds get to
that number I think to the magic 30
number absolutely you know thus though
what to me what could be the big
difference maker had folks here from
Atlanta know all about Sony Michele and
what he did in Georgia what he's been
and what he did to the Chargers and then
what he did to the Chiefs he has been
remarkable
I mean he's setting records for rookies
and it's not just because you know
they're handing him the ball in the two
yard line he's running it between the
20s like a beast they're blow open
they're blowing open holes for him
Brady's getting the ball out two and a
half seconds tops
he doesn't have to throw it beyond the
sticks never and there's still dashing
people that's why I'm concerned for the
Rams right here because if Sony Michelle
can do to the Rams what everyone was
kind of doing to them in the last half
of the season they might be in some
trouble tonight well I look at the way
they have played of late once they got
to keep to lead back and wave was able
to play in a more aggressive style you
look at what they did to Ezekiel Elliott
you know obviously shut him down and
then the New Orleans Saints run game
they shut him down and not I really
think is because they were able to play
a little bit more aggressive because
they can play aggressive on on outside
at the cornerbacks position I think
you're right but I think we'll see way
devise a scheme to try to take the
inside run game away from the Patriots
because you have to and dama kansui is
gonna be critical in this game critical
to stopping the run yeah and it's his
first foray into this big game too
I mean I'm looking forward to it I
really AM it's just playmakers all over
the lot and then you've got I'm just
wondering if McVeigh knows what Bela
check will try to do he knows what Bela
check does usually with first-time
quarterbacks in the first time situation
which Golf is obviously he's won a
couple of playoff games this year I'm
wondering what McVeigh does the counter
I'm really looking forward to this whole
chess match because these both these
guys are special all I'm early I think
early Sean is gonna go down Phil to
Brandon cooks just the threat of Brandon
running past those guys early on right
remember Philly they did that last year
now Sean Jeffrey Wright ran past them
got the long toast
I'll pass and then you know Clemente yep
went up them scene for another long
that's good to me that's that's where
you can have the Patriots if you throw
the ball down the field yeah I can man
hit him it early I mean I can't I really
this is exciting
now I'm beginning to turn the page a
little bit here towards Super Bowl 53 in
a way we're getting close for good what
do you think Phillip Rivers is thinking
today LT have you spoken to him since
the I have not I have not but I'm I'm
sure he's thinking uh get back on the
horse get back on horse and try the game
because you have to believe that he
believes they have the team to make
another run at this they were terrific
this year everyone was calling the most
complete team and then got deleted yeah
I mean within a span of literally 15
minutes you know it just I don't know if
it was just me but maybe you saw this it
just looked like to me they were
sleepwalking in the first half like they
just I don't know they were still tired
well at that trip it looked to me like
they were a team that went to Denver in
week 17 that went to Baltimore and week
18 and then had to get up to play the
Patriots in week 19 and in the last two
weeks it was 10:00 a.m. in their mental
clock yes
that's what that's what it look like to
me too yeah but does that sound like an
excuse I mean you know it is enviable
it's a fact
run it's an undeniable fact this
football though I mean it you have to be
ready to play but the facts are that if
you're not ready to play and it seemed
like they weren't ready to play as a
competitor and and a player I'm gonna
take advantage of you
just cuz you're not and I really don't
hear that you're not ready to play I'm
gonna take advantage of it so you are
not part of the pregame show right I am
NOT you are not because you're on after
host game on game day prime yes with
charissa Thompson Shannon Sharpe and I
and our guy Deon Santino's 34:30 looks
dynamite you've seen any of these bits
there's a screening here later in town
today I got invited to get by
I mean appearances I know you're not
consistent people anymore but I mean
he's your team man yeah yeah I got
invited I can't make it to but you know
I mean rich but he's coming by here
tomorrow yeah okay and you're gonna make
plug buddy no one's gonna get the call
now they're gonna literally show up yeah
person yeah so Shannon's here -
everybody's coming here this is you're
gonna get home they probably working on
Shannon of course what you know because
he loves undisputed by the way I'm on a
3:00 a.m. flight home whoa yes so I
gotta be in the Rich Eisen show chair at
9:00 a.m. Pacific time on Monday because
there is an iron-rich and Eisen but I'm
a team player you know I'm gonna be
there what's with shares you are you
should beat you on that flight um I
don't think he's he's not always a team
player have you always a team player
okay all right by the way I like I like
stirring it up between LaDainian
Tomlinson and Shannon Sharpe it's great
to see Lt you're a good man you're a
really good man and I'm thrilled to be
calling you a teammate even though you
know I don't get anything for it a
physical nature just you being a friend
and you being you you always do take the
call and I always appreciate you coming
by here I truly do do you got the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience